can you give me your best opening line
that you I can use on tinder everything
I think of makes me die a little inside
if you're looking for opening lines then
you are already dead inside hi there I'm
Evangeline Lilly and this is love line
I'm here today to solve all of your love
dilemmas Fiona says my boyfriend keeps
farting when we're in bed together
I still think farts are funny mm-hmm it
makes me feel sick but he finds it funny
I won't stop doing it please help Oh
Fiona you are asking the wrong woman
I used to trap farts and jars and make
my sister smell them and sometimes I
would hotbox the bed and I'd shove her
face under the covers like wrong person
I think farts are [ __ ] hilarious
Lauren Lauren has written in because
this guy she's just started going out
with his really small feet she knows for
the first time when they went bowling
and he got given the smaller shoes the
size really matter um does size matter
absolutely every time it might be the
most important thing in the world
[Music]
Jasmine Jasmine has written in my work
crush is going on a high profile TV
dating show just one exists I didn't
know that existed why aren't I watching
that show Oh like bachelor and
bachelorette that's disgusting himself
and I'm terrified he will find love what
should I do
the thing is Jasmine if he claims to
have found true love on a dating show
you just dodged a bullet all right Susie
Susie was written in can you give me
your best opening line that you I can
use on tinder everything I think of
makes me die a little inside if you're
looking for opening lines then you are
already dead inside your charm alone
should be enough please don't try
pick-up lines they will never ever work
so but if you are absolutely and
completely desperate and you must use a
pick-up line one time when I was in New
York I was walking down the street and a
man walked walked up to me and he held
up his cellphone and he said excuse me
but there's something wrong with my cell
phone might she be able to help me and I
said listen I'm probably the most
technologically on the savvy person I
know you've asked the wrong woman and he
said no I think you can actually help me
with this problem see the problem with
my phone is your numbers not in it Tony
Tony
the female Tony has written in what
outfit should I wear for my first date
with this guy I'm kind of into him we're
going for a romantic dinner Tony what
makes you feel like a badass
[ __ ]
because whatever that is where that time
listen guys I have one last piece of
advice for you
whatever you do when it comes to your
love life never ever never take another
person's advice thank you for joining me
I hope that it helps
[Music]